hello
are we live
think so
[Music]
[Music]
like how fast does this go live when i
actually press it we're here
all right lit
what up people
welcome
we'll see how i feel about chat being on
the right side
i changed some stuff up
very small things but
see how it looks i'm very curious to see
how the stream looks now of the sarong
account whoops
whoops different account
hola everybody how are we doing today
welcome to the stream
i'm a robot apparently all right
good morning
um
it's rick baby
no i don't want to watch stuart little i
don't
hey you have a great day at work john
welcome everybody
so i'm curious of how the stream looks
now because it could be better or it
could be worse i have no idea
hopefully it looks better just like
video quality wise
godskin video was super cool yeah we're
gonna have to talk about that
we're gonna have to talk about that a
little bit
dude rick
looks powerful today very powerful
oh i have a pop filter coming from my
microphone today too it didn't get here
before the stream started
but uh
[Music]
that should be nice
is it 1440p
very well could be
what up people
yes i am cosplaying as the hardest boss
indeed
yo
maybe godskin isn't that far off and
what the lyrics said according to daniel
no i agree we're going to talk about
this stuff bro we're going to talk about
all this stuff
yeah yep we're going to talk about it
first off
does the video quality look good
that i need to know first
then we'll get into everything else
joy gets belly rubs 24 7 by all members
of my family so your sub definitely went
toward the belly ropes
yes
is am i too loud is the game too loud
see when you mess around with video
quality
other stuff gets messed up sometimes too
it looks great alright sick
that's poggers
what are these
anyway
all quests
all bosses
that's what we're doing
[Music]
damn she doing the splits
[Music]
all right
that's godfrey's big cereal bowl okay
good all right so i guess i guess it
looks good all right foggers we'll take
it
we'll take it man all right voice can
come down a tad all right
oh you're right it was in the red
how does this sound
is this right where we want it
we like this right here
[Music]
yeah yeah
doing some yoga
is that crispy crispy
that sound good
i lit
is this microphone supposed to be right
up next to my face bro
[Music]
okay
iota
oh that is sketch okay
perfect
extra crisp try screaming
no i don't want to scare people
how far are you into this play through i
have no idea we're just kind of going
with it man
yeah the pop filter will help when i go
then it won't make that stupid noise you
hear
that's coming today
so next stream
tomorrow probably be awesome
please scream
i don't know if i'm capable of screaming
i'm sure i'll scream at some point
right
too dirty
hey too dirty man
all right guys
press one in chat if you want to talk
about reddit
because the last couple days have been a
little dramatic
please quietly scream
there you go six two this is what i
wanted to see i didn't want to see any
ones
69
nope
just bosses
and quest lines as close as we can
[Music]
nope haven't heard of that conan
anyway oh yeah we beat morgot
because we're the best
yeah 8008 exactly oh wait hold on i
messed up
there we go
what's up with [ __ ] reddit again now
hey listen
can we get some can we get some claps in
the chat if that's possible here
that this reddit thing has nothing to do
with me
wow
incredible
didn't think it was possible
wow
oh there are claps in here good good
good
perfect
either these are these all like
scriptures
you see this
well i know what i'm doing
burrito
i've played the game through many times
like the reason the game takes so long
to beat at first is because you have no
idea where you're going and you're just
like walking around
all right all right all right we'll talk
about it
you talking about the plagiarism thing
no this is something completely
different
uh if you guys saw the godskin video
we're just gonna get into it now if you
guys saw the godskin video
then
you should go check the pin comment
because it looks like
i don't know what i'm doing
what's up there
let me up
anyway
it looks like the translations aren't
accurate
or
here's what happened okay
daniel put out his video
i thought it was poggers
um because i know no latin obviously
um made a video on it it out daniel it's
all lit
everything was cool
oh no i'm stuck
some dude on reddit made a
reddit thread
about why daniels translations are wrong
and he calls him out for faking
translations like he's just faking [ __ ]
for views
um
the reddit thread went viral people
started hate raiding on daniel and then
reddit thread mod or reddit moderators
uh took down the thread because they
just started
[ __ ] on him unfortunately
um in my opinion i don't think daniel
had any
like ill intent to fake translations i
think the dude actually knows some latin
and did his best
which since then
um
he's changed the title to fan
like fan translate like fan fan
translation i can't talk yet
band translation instead of like actual
translation so
yeah
no it's not like how fake 100
it it just doesn't matter the expert
latin dude said that none of it makes
any sense none of it like
whatever yeah this is the daniel thing
we're talking about
so
yeah
yeah so here's here's my take okay like
just real quick
originally and this was like less than a
week ago right
daniel
daniel's video without him asking by the
way
daniel's video was put up by somebody
else onto reddit
and that reddit thread had like 27 000
likes right with everyone in the
comments saying like holy [ __ ] this is
super awesome like
great job daniel this is really cool
like everyone was pogging out over it
because it is a really cool find
you know if it were 100 true but it
looks like it's not anyway
everyone was going crazy giving them all
kinds of support he went from like 500
subscribers on youtube to like 6 000 in
like a day it's like good for you dude
that's freaking awesome
so everyone was giving him love
tens of thousands of people giving him
love
and then one dude makes a reddit thread
talking about how he's wrong
and then tens of thousands of people
just flip the script completely
and start hate raiding the dude
that's what i don't like
because for whatever reason
reddit immediately goes to well daniel
purposely did every like faked his
translations for views
where i don't think that's true at all i
think he knows some latin and he did his
best
and whether it meant anything or not
it's like a fan translation like it's a
[ __ ] theory like whatever
you know
and
but people just go and [ __ ] on him
immediately i think that's stupid
and like apparently that's just what
reddit does all the time like but they
just go yeah it's a mob mentality it's
so bad
um
i just they go from loving him to hating
him in like less than a day or something
i'm just like
that's what i don't like and whether or
not the translations are are are right
or wrong we're never gonna know because
we'd have to ask the composer
but
it's just so
i don't like the raid mob mentality that
happens on reddit
i really don't it's awful and coming
from you know i went through this like a
month ago
it [ __ ] sucks bro it's horrible
like my mental state after that was so
bad
constantly worried about everything
daniel seems to be handling it really
well like he's just he changed the title
to fan theory and he's just letting it
ride it's like all right whatever
you know
but i've never dealt with something like
that before so that's why i struggled
with it
but
yeah literally almost every word in
latin has like a thousand different
meanings or something like there's a
reason nobody speaks latin anymore
also daniel could be right
we just don't know nobody really knows
you could be a latin expert and i i feel
like an expert would be like yeah this
could be right
it's probably not but it could be
which he didn't say
so that reddit thread hating on daniel
was taken down because people were hate
raiding on him i'm assuming that's the
reason
i don't know but if i had to guess
that might be it
if i had to guess
we'd have to ask the composer
and also i'm not trusting someone on
reddit who claims themselves to be
a
uh latin expert
he very well could be i don't know i
don't know
i don't know
but
the the hate raid on daniel is so dumb
that's what i didn't like
but the but the threat was taken down
like i was saying
and then
[Music]
what's his name scott
jund
you guys know
uh he's like he's a pretty big youtuber
he has like 150 000 subs or something
like that
yeah yoda's a homie
i think scott jund or scott judd
something like that
made a video talking about this calling
it like uh
elden ring drama or whatever is it scott
jund okay
and he made like a three minute video on
the whole thing
talking about what happened and he's
saying like i don't know why daniel
would uh lie
about his translations or like make [ __ ]
up and i'm like i don't think he did i
don't think he made anything up i think
he had his own interpretation of what it
means
and he did his best he put it out there
here's the other [ __ ] thing that's
annoying
daniel didn't put up the reddit thread
of him of his translations he didn't put
it up someone else did
so he didn't ask for any of this reddit
publicity
at all
and then all of a sudden it's just [ __ ]
[ __ ] on him
all day
for like two days straight now
you guys get what i'm saying
yeah it's a lore playthrough kinda sorta
oh i'm i'm gonna roll through the entire
game with this cosplay bro
yeah it's not like he asked for any of
this i'm sure he wanted it to
but i just feel bad for the guy because
reddit's [ __ ] on him because that's
what they do on reddit
also vatividia
commented on scott's video
putting out his own little thing about
it saying like we're not we're not gonna
know only the composer knows and this
happens every time a new game comes out
which didn't really help daniel at all
but
whatever needless to say i don't like
reddit
i don't
i don't like the i don't like the
website
they're mean
no i'm not saying [ __ ] bhati body's cool
i like vati makes it fantastic videos
redditors is the topic
yeah kinda it just has nothing to do
with me though i'm just talking about
some [ __ ] drama that's been going on
in eldon ring
all right we'll continue
posted a bit about it being translated
what the [ __ ] is happening here i just
talked about that you forehead
anyway
[Music]
yeah i think reddit as a site is awesome
but i think the people some people in it
can i say most people in reddit or
should i say some
do you think redditors have sex i think
some of them do
i think a lot of them don't
yeah it's like this such bottom tier dog
[ __ ] drama to be honest but like
whatever
whatever bro
okay i have my runes
oh yeah dark souls 3 is really
it's a pretty easy game we're gonna have
to play that at some point after we
finish this
most active posters
it's like the more karma you have
probably the less sex you have i would
imagine
soldier of godric versus chuck norris
what you're talking about there is the
end of the world is another way to say
that fight
[Music]
what percentage are you at right now
i mean we're here we're in the capital
so
50
i don't know
probably less than that
yeah we're gonna definitely do some mods
for this game in the future as well
that's gonna be fun
[Music]
yeah aren't people making a lot of
comparisons to the anime
berserk to this game
oh yeah we gotta go change our faith up
don't we
oh yeah okay i know what to do now sorry
yeah i just thought i'd talk about that
at the beginning and then we can just we
can just freaking play bro
this is a
that's a good breakdown that's a good
breakdown great good one
okay i need to go down there
who's your favorite boss in elden ring
radon 100
radon
radon's a lit
how long do you until we see an elden
ring expansion
you mean a dlc or like another game
uh dlc i'd say like a couple more months
maybe
we might be close to dlc i don't know
i don't i don't know
why is it so
probably because it's night time you
idiot
[Music]
oh yeah zion storms awesome
i'm i like his videos a lot he's cool
lore hunter is great as well
they make really good videos oh
was that you yeah yes the master is
still ceased
and after coming all this way
why now i need to turn up their volume i
can't hear them
who exactly was radican
the master is stumped his finger has
remained still ever since radigan's name
was radagon is america but oh
how important i'm telling you this
ratagon is america ratagon is america
why must these qualms come to you now
we were on the very cusp
oh champion gundyr easy bro i could fist
that guy and he'd die
dry finger
butthole
sorry i'm taking a drink
[Music]
zion made a similar video to your last
video with reichard cool
love it
feels so good sitting for hours watching
a stream after a long day having the
shitty virus you have coveted
what's her damage look like
nice
oh
my game at my game freezing
that's a lot of damage bro
all right do i already have the
incantation is that why i'm tripping
right now like what a slow start to the
stream i am so sorry
no we don't we don't have it
all right where do i get the in wait
where is it i remember
what are you drinking i'm drinking
something called lilo light
which is called calm in a can
so i'm very calm
where do we get this again
the uh incantation the continuous quest
line
hora lewis giga chad
gundyr's resident sleeper
broom second floor of eartry sanctuary
did i not grab that
i totally grabbed that
i was just in there and it wasn't there
do i not get it from him
this forehead
oh do i have to give it to
the gold mask
oh i give it some muriel don't i you
no
muriel
miriam
why do i
i just didn't grab that out there did i
man i'm an idiot
over here
we gotta go get to the dog the dog
pope you can give it to corn too it he
didn't he didn't want it he didn't ask
for it
he's like nah
yeah i gotta learn it but i don't have
any
guys i forget a lot of things all the
time
okay
more wise ratagon is stronger than all
the demigods right
ratagan's a god
so
nerds
thank you
yeah the carrying knight swords okay
oh wow
i was looking at chat oh shoot
all right let's go bro
let's go bro
nice one good shot good stuff
oh [ __ ]
bro
get out of here
damn it
i can't even hit this guy
bruh
[Music]
yeah melania is a demigod
everyone's a uh
america and radagon are gods
[Music]
gonna die
[Music]
just kidding i'm the best
bruh
bro
bruh
[Music]
i should probably fight him on touring
huh where are you going sir hello
i thought that would kill the horse
there we go baby
bro i'm drinking
technically tea right now i don't think
that's weird at all bibs
well the elden beast is a manifestation
of the greater will itself so
the elden beast is an outer god
manifestation of the outer god
ronnie is technically a god when we
become elden lord when we have her
ending
um but she is a demigod before that
yeah i don't think i think you can drink
tea all the time
wait what action war did i get i wasn't
paying attention because i'm stupid also
i probably shouldn't have this on
anymore
you guys think i'm stupid
wait reduces damage and impact of head
shots
uh
raises defense when hp is low
um
oh there we go
ice spear
can i put that on this just to see
no
see if i asked that on twitch everyone
would have said yes so thank you
i immediately got distracted
okay
what was i doing
ash of war
yeah i can't do that
thank you dark knight jake uh do you
think the flower outside of melania's
boss room is from her
from melania
i think it's from one of uh her sisters
i don't i wouldn't i don't know if it's
from uh melania herself
that's very possible because uh
well yeah because uh
she's bloomed three times
so it could be
give me debt
give me dead
what do you think do you know anything
about the giant albanoric and snow
fields
there's a giant almond earth in the
story
[Music]
oh yeah
at the end of
latinas questline right
no i haven't looked into that enough
very cool though
idiot
people 100 percent
have a randomizer stream of a thousand
percent
i would love to fight melania right off
the rip that would be great
i miss bro
there we go
hardest boss in the game right there
right guys
artist bosses
we got that death root though baby
yeah it could be
millicents or one of her uh sisters
uh the bloom outside of the boss room
i am the soldier of god himself
hardest to lose
imagine being that guy huh
[Laughter]
i'm really hyper today i hope that's
okay
idiot
why am i so hyper i have no reason to be
hyper
where are my lore videos i'm making one
i'm almost done writing a new one
you guys are gonna like it
can you stream more i would like to
it is a small bloom
through
dude i need to research the painter more
that would be a cool video as well
what are we doing again
oh yeah turtle
no sorry dog
my bad
what's the next video about i can't tell
you that
you kidding me
then it wouldn't be a surprise
we are going to
hope dog
pope dog
i still think uh melinda is the glomide
queen
or she's a fragment of the of the full
power of the glomei queen that we can
see at the end of the flame of frenzy
ending
what i think melina is throughout the
game is just trying to get us to release
destin death that's her whole point
you guys really want the boat boss lore
i have an unpopular plane in the frame
of flensy india is honestly my least
favorite personally hey
if you don't like it you don't like it
that's all there is to it baby
all right can you teach me this
greetings
do you wait wait wait wait wait
uh
this
we we gotta we gotta get his voice up
we're gonna put that down a little bit
we're gonna put that down a little bit
voice is always all the way up
is there something else oh that's so
much better
okay uh give prayer book
give a dragon cult prayer book oh what
have we here
very well let us both learn together
heresy is not native to the world
it is but a contrivance do you think
melania is only a spirit like ronnie yes
i do
give scroll
oh what have we here
very well let us both learn together
heresy is not native to the world
it is but a contrivance thank you all
things can be conjoined all things can
be conjoined people
all things
okay
is this the one we want chat
where we need 37 in for
it's the law of regression right
to do uh korin's questline i think it is
i think melania is a fragment of the
glomide queen
so when ronnie took a fragment of the
rune of death
it released melania into the world as
well
my my theory is that when america
ordered maliketh
to seal the rune of death
malacath
defeated
the glomide queen and sealed her along
with the rune of death
into
uh the black blade
when we killed him and released it
melano was released or the frag or uh
the glomide queen was released from it
as well which is why at the flame of
frenzy ending we can see her
or she's a full or she's the full glow
my queen the whole way through
because
yeah there's there's so many like
[ __ ]
bro this game's so confusing because
there's so many things
all right so i learned it now i need to
go and get was it 37 int do i have two
larval tiers so i can get back to where
i am
that's important
where do i look at alert
i don't even think i have one larval
tear bro
wait
um
no i don't have a larval tear
[Music]
could be
yeah i i don't know why it wouldn't take
faith to do this but it's intelligence
if she's the glomite queen who's her
mama
probably queen america
because i believe we found that
um the glomite queen was one of
america's kids
go to no chron kill the mimic
oh yeah we should go to no crime look
can't we go to no chron like right here
no
oh my god i haven't been to nocron yet
well we got to do that
i already killed the bear
yeah yeah
we haven't even been to nochron yet
we are slacking bro
what up there you are
shall we commence
shall we
okay
i think melano was what ronnie looked
like before we killed her body
potentially
the body at the top of the carrion tower
though is way bigger than melania
way way larger
there we go
let me tear also in altus we can we can
get a few down here we're good we're
solid
we're solid baby we gotta we gotta go
kill we have to battle the soldier of
godric
we have to go fight rick himself
this is gonna be tough guys i don't know
if we can do this
i don't know if we can do this
it's gonna be the toughest boss in the
game
i want to look at chat but i also want
to fall to my death
as i say that i'm dead
you're rick he's an imposter
yeah but he still has my power
melano said herself that her person was
given by your mother inside the earth
tree
it's definitely america i i 100 believe
that america is melana's
mother and i think america the glow my
queen
is a child of america as well
sent to disperse
destined death
you guys should just wait a couple more
days for the video not that i'm saying
i'm making a video on that but
something like it
spoilers
spoilers
what am i stuck on bro
godfrey who daddy then
what's up pale blood
morning's going fantastic how about you
you telling us our maiden isn't real
i mean she tells you that from the start
by the way
he straight up tells you that i'm not
really a maiden but i can play the role
of it
so
yeah
it's nothing compared to the true power
of rick don't let the false god deceive
you
i feel you i feel you
i'll do my best
what is flickering do you guys see that
flickering at the top of the screen oh
was that
nerd
oh
i'm so sorry
all right press one in chat first time
you saw this you pooped your pants
as i did i pooped
physical
i don't like messing with them
patches versus chuck norris
i think we all know the answer to that
e
a sports
it's in the game
e
all right
the hardest fight i could ever imagine
soldier of god rick
back off
me what is he doing
no i don't do that
i have magic in my inventory though
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh you're cheating
lol
[Music]
that's bad
[Music]
why is the audio getting weird
stop it
get some help
we did it
we have defeated god himself we need one
more larval here and then i'll be
comfortable
god himself is dead
nothing can stop us now
be gone heretic
thou art trash at game
oh come on bro
what happens if you stomach for mimic
tests are there two of them yeah it's
funny
it's it's it's pretty epic
what do we want to level at this point
strength
i got two
i got two
did i really
don't lie bro
eight
you all be lying sometimes
we're good
let's get the frick out of here man
[Music]
did you pick up the mimic summon yet not
yet i'm not sure if i want to do that
but we will
i think we will because we got to go
down there anyway
all right what did we need
37 inch everything else doesn't matter
for now ah is it thy wish
oh i should take a picture of what i
have now shouldn't i
yeah hold on
hold on i would
because i i want to get right back to
where we were
yeah int
i took a pic
we're good
a girl messaged me chat imagine
37
you don't have to take a pic well i did
anyway brady
because i'm scared okay
thanks
and also it doesn't
37 and everything else doesn't matter
for now
we're just gonna go full vigor i don't i
don't care all right we'll be back
thanks mommy
all right everything off
let me get rid of that real quick
let's go
oh wait still gotta put it on
it showed what you had before
oh
it does you're right
well
i don't like the way you said it
there
hey i said nothing about sex chad i
don't know what any of you were talking
about i said a girl messaged me
that don't mean nothing
most of the time i'm giving relationship
advice to the girls that message me okay
i'm so hard in the friend zone it's nuts
i am so hard in the friend zone
i'm just [ __ ] with you brady you're
fine
[Music]
oh god you're right i shouldn't say that
word
i think this chat will always be horny
all times
it's rough eh i don't care
[Music]
all right people
i don't have a thing do i
thank god
i still can't do it
[Music]
yeah i can okay
you guys ready for this
that is so cool i love that
ratagon
is america
wow
a twist
a twist you could say
spoken by a friend zone person yeah
r
equals m
how many hours would you say you have in
this game 350.
my girlfriend of six years goes to me
three times before she actually agreed
to go on a date with me
see
it's possible
see
all right he's looking the other way
we're good
we're good
getting friend zoned is better than
getting somebody who wants you for your
twitch views no kidding dude
yup
i know that feeling
oh
was that you
yes the master is still ceased and after
coming all this way
why now of all times
uh
about who exactly was oh yeah i have to
tell him we've already heard all this
tree why must these things go up
thanks
you
ratagon is america
order totality
it's not working okay
what on earth did you do to the master
well not that i'm complaining
master's finger moves again resuming his
concentration does it wasn't good enough
for me
i haven't the words to thank you
so i'd like to pass this on to you
audio
[Music]
documented by yours truly
well
that was annoying
to think
that radican was marika herself
or at least
such is all i can interpret from the
rhythm and calculus of his finger
everyone just scream along with me i
told you we'd scream at some point
sadly i cannot comprehend it myself
do you have a fuller understanding yeah
the audio was
it just went nuts
well
either way because of the truth and
continue my documentation
when in truth it matters very little
whether i understand the master's
thoughts or not
i am merely his scribe damn
it is my soul and unwavering purpose
you kind of sound like a young peter
griffin
all right bye
[Music]
why am i a lore creator i feel like i'm
such a weirdo
you know what i mean
i create lore videos and i'm such an
idiot
meg
get out meg
ben
now bear with me
[Music]
so does it really
does it really say the thingy
really tell you no
because it tells you what you had before
so we're gonna go back 40
11
22
whoops
32
the witness
oh that one was good what the hell oh
yeah
wait
wait
wait
why are we at 82 already i'm confused
11 22 32.
36
what's happening
i'm confused it says i had 40
11
22 32 36.
can i not go back down
i mean i only lose out on
like five dexterity
40 40 11 22 32 36
oh
wait did i lose my great room no i don't
think so
bigger was 37 i took a picture and it
says 40.
if you add stat boosting gear it'll
throw off the stats alright whatever
it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine
we good
why is it lagging oh my controller
disconnected
might have been because of that
rick returns
next talisman
i didn't remove any talismans oh that's
it okay we're good we're fine
we're good
all right now what do we do
where do you guys want to go chat
you decide
strength make big sword go swoosh
no kron you want to continue in no chron
aight
let's keep going
[Music]
popping it
hello what are you
oh
[Music]
i think we've been in the sewers
so i'm pretty sure corwin now goes to
the mountaintops of the giants
did you get the ghost flame torch no i
don't think so
we can kill the deer the ancestral
spirit
but yeah we still need to find alexander
in volcano manor do you guys know where
he is
no i'm not skipping the halogen tree
we'll go to the hill tree
why is my chat always horny you guys
think it's me do i do that to you
[Music]
is it my voice
yeah he's bathing in lava i just forget
where that is
no we we still need to find them in the
lava
[Music]
do you stream often
i might start streaming more
oh no i have a lot of fun streaming
he's past the fort
fortnight
fortnight
we as biological organisms are hardwired
to be horny
max
i'm gonna get you
i'm gonna get you
all right
oh [ __ ]
alright
thoughts on live golf tour i have
i don't even know what's going on i'm
gonna have to see a live golf event
before i have any opinion on the live
tour
if the event sucks then like who cares
you know
i don't think it will
but
i used to be a pro golfer to anyone in
here who doesn't know that and that's
why i'm i know about that stuff
and now i do this
amazing how life
works
[Music]
dj's smart for getting the bag
thoughts i'm not golfing anymore i do
golf
just not at a pro level anymore
yeah oh my god
stop it that hurt ow
you're a meanie
i'm doing a lot of damage man this build
is fun
this man doesn't have sex
he [ __ ]
i think you should have a face cam oh
[ __ ]
not today
but
i'm pulling it up
i'm not huge on face camps
face reveal you guys know i streamed
with the facecam on twitch for four
years right
[Music]
i vote whatever you want
i like that answer thank you
100k
i'm trying to get to 100k by the end of
the year
so that might be a while
only if you're in a bathtub
nice
jake is very ugly and bald shut up bitsy
i have a ton of hair
you're more smexy on youtube
i don't i don't know like aren't you
guys here for the game play
for the epic gameplay you're seeing
[Music]
you got 2k in three days yeah
but that's not the 8k we got in one day
once
i'm just kidding i don't even know what
i'm talking about
we did get that though oh [ __ ]
we are fine
and 70 for yes huh
um
i have a dslr camera
i have that
i just like okay let me know what you
guys think about this like be honest
about this
do you think
that a face cam adds to a stream like
really or is it just in the way
because i think if you have a good
enough voice and you talk enough during
your stream you don't even need a face
cam
that's just me though
i i think it takes up a lot of room it
looks weird like it it takes up a lot
like i don't know
but hey i'm here to please you guys
like my opinion doesn't matter honestly
you guys are the people that are here so
i'll do whatever you want
what up kyle
depends on how hyper you get
[Music]
i get hyper a lot more often now
i used to be tired all the time
now i don't even take a daily nap
i used to take a daily nap like every
single day i took a nap
can you moan
oh
i mean i'll show my face if you guys
want to i i really don't care
i just think it takes up a lot of room
on the screen
sleep apnea no
i think i was just
depressed yep the burp was my moan
rick has come for you
[Music]
i love the music in this fight
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
don't do that
holy [ __ ] i almost died i didn't realize
rick defeats legend
rick is satisfied
with death of moose
yeah he can
god love princess mononoke
princess mononoke and spirited aware
classics
legend dead
all right so you guys all voted yes for
the webcam i can uh you know i can do it
maybe maybe we'll think of i'll think
about it
i don't know why i just said it like
that
i'll put it on the radar all right
it's on the radar
wow 100 votes
i'm not shy do i sound shy
know
i have to set up the camera again though
my hair is getting really long though
trying to grow it out
i like how you can see mogan's palace
every time you get no crown reminding
you that there's something up there yeah
dude my first playthrough i had no idea
how to get up there i didn't find
melania or moog in my first playthrough
i just didn't know how to get up there
[Music]
i don't think they're connected to the
hand enemies nerd i don't
yeah that's the other thing if i use a
webcam then i like i can i have to
shower
[Music]
i have to shower bro
like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
do i even fight this guy
yes
i do
um
i will destroy you
i didn't know he could just do that
i believe i can stagger this guy right
oh
yeah showerings for nerfs
like i'm a youtuber so i don't have to
shoot
oh that's bad
i feel better about it
now okay
also
and i'm not saying this to say that i
don't shower because i do
usually daily shower right i usually
shower every day
but does anyone else hear in the chat
hate taking a shower
okay if only if you guys were on twitch
yeah they can stagger i think
see
he's
that's so unfortunate
[Applause]
oh
dude the arrow almost caught me there
see i ain't showering maybe i'm weird
for that
i find it annoying
and i think it's i only hate it just
because
wow
wow
wow
it's refreshing dude i shower every day
i'm not stinky okay i'm not
dude honestly i hate fighting both
versions of the crucible knight
kyle if akmar says the same thing one
more time i want you to time them out
cause i said no already
i don't wash my hair every day but i do
wash my body every day see that's what i
do i have long hair as well terminator
but
i don't wash my hair every day and i
also don't think it's healthy to do so
for your hair
at least from what i've been told
but my hair is pretty long like it goes
to my shoulders now
see
staggered can i knock him off here
no
let's go
oh man that was nice huh
okay
wow that shield is the best shield in
the game
what's up trey
what level is this build
82
it's a soldier of god
named rickville
all right where's dee's brother yo what
up these brother
hand over twin armor set
nice kyle
good moderating kyle
[Music]
that's what he sounds like
showering every day is fine but you
can't shoe your hair every day see i've
heard like that you can and i've heard
that you can't i just like i shampoo it
every now and then but
my hair actually feels more healthy when
i um
when i stopped shampooing it every day
yeah i know they're easy i just don't
like it
all right let's get d to help us with
this because this fight
smells bad
the boy gets headsets if i don't use
shampoo see i wash my my hand or my face
oh you mean you're on your head
i mean i've always had a lot of hair so
i don't even know if i have headsets
i could
where the hell is me
did he not enter the boss room
me
it says he's here
i don't know how i didn't get hit there
[ __ ]
okay
all right that's fair
that's fair
where did d go
right
right
nice dude
bro
bro
this fight sucks
are you kidding me
want one one little gripe i have about
this game why is it that the poison
hurts you all the time
like it should only hurt you when you're
actually poisoned not if you're forced
to stand in it
that it hurts
that's never been a thing in any of the
other games by the way
all right we got it we have the golden
centipede we're good i'm playing on pc
all right we're gonna make sure d's here
which fight is better this or twin man's
eaters from demon souls
i've never played demon souls or i did a
little bit
but it wasn't i didn't have a ps3 and i
played it at a friend's house
hey welcome to the party man welcome
hi
you take care of this
i need to spend those hey you don't have
to follow me
but since when does he does that do that
attack
oh i forgot
if you see where he started that attack
from he's off the ground
all right
stop bitching jake and just do it
my favorite fight
hey stop standing
all right
deep
just a normal fight
we don't [ __ ] around with that we don't
[ __ ] around with that at all
nice
that's fine
that's not
don't [ __ ] around with that
no clue how to dodge that
that's fine no big deal
you gotta run away
i'm good
you [ __ ]
really
uh
website
soldier of god
rick
was never scared
rick knew he'd win
rick is the best
are you gonna go get the crucible night
armor
nah we don't need it
why are they here
um
probably guarding the entrance to
the the depths
i would imagine
that goes up one that goes up two
let's go see if we can upgrade any of
our stuff real quick
rick is truly a god
truly a legend
i'll turn down the music a little bit i
wanted to do that before the fight but i
got a little distracted
gargle all over these nuts
well
where have you been hiding
i took you for dead
no matter it's all the same
lay out your arms i don't know why i
listened to him okay
we need one
well
we need three smithing stone fives let's
see if we can get some of that
oh this is like my eighth play through
les
no we got fours but no fives
oh wait can i turn something in
dang it
if you could be any character from elden
ring who would it be radon
or blind
do you think dseo will help understand
the lore or leave it up to
interpretation we will either
understand more or will be infinitely
more confused
[Music]
so
yeah
we don't know
okay
where
where is alexander
in this area
because i know he's sitting in a pool of
lava but how do we get to that
would be bad ass
isn't malakath like struggling
all the time with everything
to the left where there's no grace in
the lava this area right here
you gotta beat the magmorn
i have to go up here anyway
where pat just kicks you down
ah okay
we gotta we gotta find
alexander
sure
god i don't i do not want to fight the
boss at the bottom of this
but we're gonna at some point
yeah radon's also struggling quite a bit
south of fort laude
[Music]
i think we gotta go underneath
[Music]
he kicks you down over here
oh except we gotta go all the way down
no we gotta we gotta keep doing this
build we can't mess around with the
build
is there any connection to any other
from software game in eldon ring which
do you think has a strong connection
eldon ring
uh i don't think this game has a
connection lore wise to any other game
but
it feels that way because it's made by
the same developer for one and then all
of those other games inspired this one
are you a fan of star wars no not really
you to enter through the altus plateau
right do i have to go down here
and go this way
let me check real quick
this direction
yeah i i like harry potter i'm not a
giant fan of it
i love breaking bad breaking bad is one
of my favorite shows ever
it's not that way okay
near where uh raya was so over here like
here
it's kind of where i am
you gotta go in this way
like this
and we gotta go
up here
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
why is the audio so bad
the audio in this music always
pops
out guys hear that
it sounds off
[Music]
[Music]
maybe it's just me
it actually sounds like a propeller
right now
putting out for a second it sounded
weird to me maybe it was just me though
yeah i think we're i think we're going
and going there terrinator
we're going in that direction
this way
yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember this area
now
[Music]
it's just me okay good
perfect yo it's cole what up cole
just so you know coal is better than all
y'all
let's get that out of the way first and
foremost everyone bow down to coal
i'm just kidding y'all are great
y'all are pretty cool
[Music]
all righty roo let's get this up
only one level goddamn we're looking
good [ __ ]
it is true cool you are superior in
every way
a gideon spy
imagine
why is he lame
how could you say that
paul is the elden lord
ow god that was cringe
yeah there's a fort over here right
a fortnight
let me look over here real quick
ew these frogs are awful
what to fly
was there a seed
where
oh my god you're right
good call out good call out
good shake and [ __ ]
serious weird
i think i've only been down here the one
time
i cleaned my room before stream did
anybody else do that
um
[Music]
yeah we're gonna do our best dope dwarf
we're gonna do our best
get as close as we can
who dares speak cole's name in vain
you shall be met with
unrelenting
shame
upon you and your family
shame
games
game
imagine being this guy
imagine cleaning your room
i missed a grace
where
oh i did thank you
that's fine
40 second delay
oh my god imagine
should we use godric's great rune or
research hp upon defeating enemies
i was a little stuck i'm fine now though
we'll show which one should we use
godric reichardt or radon
yeah justin bieber's cool
dude i'm really far away
so
i don't
yeah godric's is the best out of these
right
all right let's keep it going
let's keep it rolling moving
up here
yeah job searching huh nice
whoa
it's the magma worm oh my god what the
[ __ ] bro
or
these fights suck
you're tripping
so
oh that doesn't count
now we're standing
and that came in hot
get it
because it's a lava
bro like what the [ __ ]
dude
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good
bro
these fights are so bad
[Music]
i get another stack
thank you
all right it's over
we did it
i think i see alexander
oh torey doesn't like
damn bro
he's heated
how we doing man you good
ah good sir
what business might you have in such a
place is this
i hardly think you're here to temper
yourself with flame no i'm not i'm not
an idiot
your
timing though is impeccable as ever
i've been making just the thing for you
on my journey here oh he threw it to me
i'm sure it'll suit you to a t
jar let's go
it's hardly more than lukewarm here i
won't be able to temper my body such
that it'll never crack again
i must just be bad at the game alone too
and can't beat that dick he's got to
keep trying man
above the lofty clouds the ice giant's
peak doth saw
here
lieth the flame of ruin
whichever burning wars
neat perhaps i'll head eastward there's
an old saying i've caught wind of
above the lofty clouds the icy giant's
peak doth soar
here lieth the flame of ruin whichever
burning roars
you good
[Music]
so
perhaps he goes to the mountaintops of
the giants now right
i believe
perhaps i'll head eastward
did we help millicent already
does anyone remember if we helped
millicent because i think we did she was
here
and we talked to her
he goes to the mountaintops of the
giants to help us with the fire giant
and then he's in pharah missoula
he is trying very hard to be a worthy
warrior unfortunately but he is
yeah pharaoh as well as last
i think we got to go to fair missoula
now i'm trying to think of other things
that we need to do
um because we can always come back and
beat all the bosses
um just quest line stuff we beat the
dung eater
um do we need to go see the dung eater
underground again oh yeah he's still
there okay
that's what we need we need all of the
uh
all the thingies
we could also go into the sewers
um
for moog
or the spirit of moog
yeah we need seed bed curses
could we do that at any point in our run
you know i think we can go to the
mountaintops um
i think we go to the mountaintops i'm
gonna make sure that we don't beat we
don't light the fire before we do
i think we'll be good until we do that
oh my god have we done any of box
questline
[Music]
it's mogan time
now we need all the seedbed curses
before we go to the dung eater um
have we done bach
there he is
i think we can we can pepper him along
right here real quick
hey bach
i just didn't give this to you did i
here you go man you just been laying
here this whole time
you got it back for me oh god my sewing
needle
who cares box useless anyway oh come on
he's doing his best
what made you go into a thing like he's
fine my mom
he's fine
they all do die at the end
he's just so worthless
and i feel bad for him
don't you okay now he should be over
here
right here
box the best boy
yes you can save bach if we have the
you're beautiful
hello wonderful please help where's the
beautiful one
if i rest and get up you should be here
areas
good to see you
master
do you remember me
we'll go check on selling as well human
you helped me before and retrieved
myself he just cries a lot please master
well some people can't be as strong as
we are
i
can't make nothing oh the creepy lady
village okay i'm happy to make
adjustments to your garments
master
i was wondering
do you ever permit village adjustments
to your garb yourself
i would well i think i know what you're
talking about let me do the job when
possible please also chat i have to pee
i'm gonna let bach talk wow
um just because i don't care about him
that much uh i'm gonna go pee
oh he's already not talking anyway
oh
i'll be back so soon
please do be safe on your journeys
so
[Music]
[Music]
weiner balls
may chaos
take
the world
that sounds awesome master
and thank you i appreciate it
okay
let's go check on selling
um we found her sex dungeon what do we
do after that
what do we uh what do we need
there you are shall we commence
[Music]
yeah shouldn't give me any other
dialogue right now what do i do to
expose her
[Music]
gotta find those two sorcerers
[Music]
the azer spells wasn't that over here
where we were
oh god
damn it
oh
that was a really sus way to put it i
mean
that's what happened bro
so it was here
one's one's in caled
i should keep going up the hill here
anyway hold on
hold up
tray did you just kill every npc that
you came across
i think you should side with jiren but
then don't get the armor set
now
yeah we'll see we'll see
he's she's connected to the old geezer
in red main castle
okay
i'm gonna go get common azer though
we've been to the we've been to the one
in uh
weeping peninsula
i usually hit them if they don't give
additional dialogue i probably would
have should have waited yeah yeah
yep
yep
i don't want to fight jiren i like jaron
i don't really care that much about
selling why did i not do that
why did i run all this way
can anyone explain my stupidity
no neither can i
i didn't even see that one was right
here
i'm stuck in the same tree
he's a witch hunter
it's so weird because
he works for radon who's a sorcerer
he's a wizard technically
they see me rolled
the hey 10
patron
catch me ride dirty
see me riding dirty
i thought that was a blood stain for a
second though
let me grab all these because i'm a
selfish little bit
okay i'm a greedy little [ __ ] gimme
gimme gimme all right all right
ooh how do i knock this over you
hit this
hit hit this
nope
isn't there a bear
i figured it out
[Music]
is jiren a dragon ball character i don't
think so
hey yo what up bear
[Music]
thank you
that's what we wanted baby
i need a smithy spot
you know how to get to the plateau above
the alden ark village
yep you got to finish ronnie's questline
hey
what
this guy drop anything
i've never played neo
i've heard it's good though
oh my god oh my god
this bear bro
i don't even think this bear can fit in
here
[Music]
he's not even gonna
try we're good
[Music]
i just have to do that every time i see
a group
okay isn't the you're beautiful in here
for box questline i think it's right
back yeah it's this right here pretty
sure yay we can save bach now does
anyone care
anyone care that we can save bach
yeah there's a demi over here with uh
someone else as well
they're like talking
yeah check this out
isn't this weird
oh [ __ ] on my dick dude
it's maggie
this is pretty much a bloodborne boss
but i can't get any health back
okay that seemed unfair
leave me alone sir
what are these fireballs dog
dude
those attacks are fast bro
i don't know why bach is everyone's
least favorite character
maybe because he doesn't really do
anything
here we go
that's i got stopped by a rock
pull off the clip
close
nicey
[Music]
and nicey
[Music]
that's who we want right there
are you gonna watch the new despicable
me movie
probably not
hey yo what up bro
give me
[Music]
can't even hurt him
okay so now
now what do we do where do we go now
thank you carlos
i want to save him
i just want to save him
i just want save him
know he's well and never have to see him
again
yeah so now i go to sell it okay
[Music]
only one thing why are you streaming on
youtube only
because i hate twitch i think which is
awful that's why
there you are
my apprentice
shall we commence the lesson
go azure searches what's this sorcery my
apprentice ah then you have seen master
azure
master azure was a founding glimstone
sorcerer and my first teacher
a stern judge of men
but he must have seen something in you
you make us both proud
we can speak more later
my apprentice
tell me your story if you recall
i was exiled from the academy of reya
lucaria
it was for attempting to restore the
primeval current of blindstone sorcery
the toothless pedentry peddled by the
karyan royal family can rot for olika
i want glimstone sorceries that open our
minds
unbound by terrestrial taboos
no matter what we give in return to see
what she looks like my apprentice
i presume nothing
teacher and student are not bound to
tread the same path
but hear me out my apprentice
i need your help to restore the primeval
current of glimstone sorcery
perhaps this is a journey we could take
together
let us journey together splendid
i thank you
this pleases me
he's pretty it's been far too long since
i found a fellow kindred spirit will she
shave you must have a fabulous teacher
yeah those legs are smooth as [ __ ] oh my
god
i have to ask a family i need your help
my apprentice master lucas she's trying
to see what she looks like
and like master the stupid helmet
from the academy
now he languishes in prison somewhere
my apprentice can you find master lussat
with this glimstone key you should be
able to cross the boundary that encloses
him
i have an idea i need him to restore the
primeval current of glimstone sorcery
after his expulsion from the academy i
heard that master lusad returned to his
home
a place called celia in the eastern
caled wilds
thinking about it
i obtained that okay i gave you from a
salient sorcerer it wouldn't be too much
of a leap to suppose he's still cooped
up nearby
okay
if i do this
yeah that didn't work let me get closer
rig okay what if i go destroy all her
[ __ ]
back here
i'm just so curious
[Music]
close
no
[Music]
we can't tell
dang it okay
all right where is this place in uh you
said it's in kaelin
[Music]
she's hollow
no
she's gone hollow
alright
where is this place
near fort pharaoh
veda
just under
like over here
oh is it this little castle over here
no that's way over there
up the hill behind millicent's church
i don't know if we can go under
[Music]
if i remember it's behind a big
graveyard that's guarded by one of those
big guys who does magic
now i'm in fighting
i feel as though i'm going the correct
direction
potentially
the hell is this
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
well this is just awful
i can barely hurt her what the hell
goodbye
is her item down there
i'm a flip
go to the church where millicent is and
up the hill
okay
why it didn't sing on latin it's
daniel's fault you guys
so over here
graveyard
big man
[Music]
big man dead
he's blood
hit the hill
range bro
[Music]
wow
celia hideaway
hey we found it we found it we're good
you have healing magic per chance you
might want it in this cave
nope
i am rick god of soldiers
[Music]
i do not need magic
[Music]
can you open map
[Music]
hello
rip
no there's a revenant no please don't
tell me there's a revenant
oh no
don't say that
oh those things are cringe dude
[Music]
see i could have been the voice actor
for the revenant
[Music]
you don't have to fight it if i don't
have to i won't
nail
nails
it's in that hole yeah i'm not going in
there
can i go in here
kind of looks like
there's a hole
if it's a boss i'll fight it
if it's not a boss hell no
going this way
[Music]
that's not good
[Music]
three crystallines
hey let's get it
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh snail
[Music]
you gotta pop this a bit early would you
say
over there
really three of them
that's three
that would be three
you're you are first
didn't even hurt
oh they got scarlet rot
the hell
probably
one at a time ladies and gentlemen one
at a time
that was good
i like how one just stands while i do
this
was it broke
oh i really would rather not die
there it is
i mean did they like
that seemed entirely too easy okay um
so i didn't find who we needed to find
it
but i'm glad i have scarlet rot now
that's great we needed to beat that
fight anyway so we're good
[Music]
i've never played a persona game now
[Music]
do i have to go down under where the
revenant is
that would have been nice earlier
thanks for the subs guys we're actually
getting close to 60k
[Music]
actually getting close
so thank you
you made them look easy well they just
kind of stood there so
i don't think it was my doing too much
[Music]
how the hell do i get down
that looks like death
scarlet rod really made me pay attention
to crafting system yeah
[Music]
so loud what's so
loud oh there's that sealed door okay
sick
oh i won't die from this height i'm just
dumb
run
i ain't [ __ ] around with the revenant
i thought i dodged i guess not
peter
what do you think you're doing here
peter
use salient seal break okay
[Music]
hey yo what up cut
[Music]
dude these guys look awesome
stars of ruin
so they're alive
kinda
all right lit
now
over here
time to do a giveaway drawing stream
um
what should we give away
i think we'll do a giveaway at 100k
my apprentice boss music cloud give me a
moment later
i have a favor to ask
[Music]
okay the form you see before you is
merely a projection
my body lies elsewhere
but the academy shackles prevent it
being moved
my body is on the weeping peninsula at
the southern tip of the lands between
imprisoned in the ruins just down from
the church of america
past the plane of the wandering
mausoleum
can you make the journey to my body
i have something that i can only trust
with you
hell yeah i can usat's location
who could have guessed
what a place to find master lusad
you have my gratitude
this is all your work oh ronnie wannabe
you guys are means to have you as an
apprentice
and a kindred spirit
this is a mere token of my thanks
please take it i'm not going up the
skirt foreheads
okay thank you this brings us a full
step closer
the bodies of masters azure
[Music]
didn't we already find her body though
yep
i guess it was selling
[Music]
we about to find out
i've only done this questline once that
was a couple months ago i don't remember
everything
i don't even think i did all of it
i did see how it ends
the bug
cringe dude
can you make the journey to my rocking
hot body you guys are all saying that
she's gorgeous is she
hello
my apprentice
thank you for coming
these shackles take a toll on us all
there is something i need you to look
after
my price yeah i would need your guys's
help with um
and my fortunes waiver you're a you're a
questline for my life
and so
i am trusted with you
myself
accept primor primal glintstone
[Music]
okay
did she just come
damn
[Music]
thank you
my apprentice
this
is my essence
nah y'all are suss
treat it
with care
[Music]
okay treated what you hold
is
good
well
now what
okay i guess i'll go back
epic
[Music]
no you're suss
no really look at me characters unmasked
videos it's cool
where'd she go
[Music]
what
i don't remember this
it's her essence oh i have it
now what do i do with it
go to the ruins near ronnie's rise
okay
[Music]
go to ronald's boss room
you guys are telling me
different things
jake you're a sim for ronnie
no she's not real
he's in a hidden room under the floor
[Music]
okay there's lots of ruins around here
[Music]
renault later okay
that looks like a hidden room under the
floor
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ]
that's an omen killer
oh my god
the hell is this
it looks like a simp
it's let me solo her
she got him
selvis puppet do not touch
touching
yeah i've played all the other souls
games
transplant primal glintstone
my apprentice
just how long has it been
thank you
you've helped me fill a new one once
again
and it's truly a gem
young and full of vigor a snug fit for
my primal glimstone
better still i've shed those awful
shackles
finally i can return to the academy
to express why are they barefoot in
royal family
and restore the pride you notice
ronaldo's barefoot as well my dear
apprentice
i owe this all to you
all right me
finally i can return to the academy
to expel the karyn royal family and
restore the primeval current
oh
my apprentice
shall we commence the lesson
as thanks for procuring this new form to
connect to earth i'll be holding you to
a higher standard
nice
we're pretty cool now aren't we all
right now where do i go
go back to her primal glintstone body
[Music]
one way out here
in this area
it says no one's there anymore
[Music]
to
the scarlet rot ruins
yeah i don't i've
i've never gotten this far in this
questline i don't think because i don't
remember any of this
go to the academy
[Music]
jaron
jarn jiren do i go here now is that
where he is
jaron's in the lake
oh
he's not here though
oh i should just do this
go to ronnie's rise tell her she smells
[Music]
nerd
[Music]
backwards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
if can never beat a pimp
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on
easy
the ruins great sword is really fun too
can go to ronaldo but jiren is at her
the ruins where selen was chained up for
more dialogue okay we'll go there
i thought you guys were telling me that
jaren was in the lake of rod i was like
really
94 94
no i i definitely want to meet jaren so
let's uh let's go back here
i literally lifted a crucible night in
the air that's kind of epic
[Music]
i love how they hired a popular creator
to
wait let me read that again i love how
they hired a popular writer to help
create the lore just to hide it all
i mean
i feel like you've never played a from
software game before
i don't see jiren
you're dead
[Music]
or boy ain't here
did you mean
here
[Music]
is this what you meant
vsauce
i don't see jiren people
oh i also didn't check if he was [ __ ]
here
[Music]
do i have to talk to him here first
sometimes he's in the church right
he's not in the chair
he would be right here
[Music]
broke your chair nerd
you have to talk to him after being in
radon
i think i did didn't i
[Music]
pretty sure i did
[Applause]
[Music]
check the academy
[Music]
outside the door
here
he's in the ruins oh okay
okay okay
[Music]
you really just standing around in here
i don't see him people
[Music]
where's he like
[Music]
[Music]
i don't see him
maybe we went too fast
[Music]
let me reload
we'll just be searching for jared the
entire next stream yeah i guess so
the bug outside the door at the academy
i was gonna go check there and you guys
said no
all right now i'm gonna go check
[Music]
that's the main academy gate whoops
i've heard a theory that the lands
between is artificial which will explain
the giant pillars in bizarre geography
[Music]
giant pillars
[Music]
um
well i think all the ruins we see around
the lance or at least in limgrave was
from pharah missoula
because pheromone as well used to be
above
limgrave
[Music]
few summoning points huh
oh there is oh
he summoned to assist sorceress selling
be summoned to challenge sorcerers helen
alright chat
up to you
i'm letting you guys pick
oh
[Music]
starting pole now starting pole now i'll
do whatever you guys want i don't care
help her kill help her kill
you decide
everyone wants us to help
up
coming back
come back a little bit keep voting
i'll wait a minute
ignore we don't want to do that
i'll wait a minute
all right it's definitely gonna be help
all right
we're doing it
the chat has spoken
bringer of my death
what does she mean by enjoying the
school when we kill him
that's interesting
i wonder why she said it like that
sorry jaren
get himself
i'll let you finish this
okay never [ __ ] mind
that was cool
[Music]
oh no way i get his armor that's
actually sick
yeah i've never gone this far in our
questline
i i feel like i've seen it though like i
watched it somewhere
did ronaldo go
what
ah my apprentice
you've saved my skin once there's no way
she's stronger than rinala right queen
of carrier there is no way she's
stronger than ronaldo
the academy can hone the primeval
current
so that we
fallen children of the stars shall beam
with brilliance once again
my apprentice wow will you stay with us
here at the academy
huh
i know it's not possible
you have your own calling
to be the next elden lord
but do think of me
of your teacher
the entire academy will swear allegiance
to the new monarch
my apprentice
become elden she told ranala there's a
baby outside and she fell for
perhaps i'm jumping ahead
but
here is a symbol of my allegiance and
the academies
oh wow that was awesome do you recall
what once i told you
that glinstone is the amber of the
cosmos and sorcery is the study of the
stars and the life therein
when you become elder lord please
illuminate me
lay bear the secrets of life which looks
like a different ending
next time
i will be your student wow
epic oh one last thing
if you fail to claim your throne
you can always pay me a visit
oh don't fret even my dullest pupils
will always have a place here
cool okay
um
i find it hard to believe that she's
stronger than ranala but okay
lit
wait what
what
what did you do
is it i wish to yet again be born
what be not alarmed
nor a fear
i would birth thee
as a sweeting
fair
she doesn't say anything different
what
what the [ __ ]
oh no
no way
oh
man
she's born a new huh
wow okay yeah i did not know this
holy [ __ ]
oh
no
so rinalda just owned her huh
thank you for your help selling
oh
well she's not dead
oh pain
well
all right
you want yeah you want to play soccer
your feet are big enough for it i mean
[ __ ] chad i mean
those are some toes right there well now
i feel awful
why did you guys let me help her oh no
all right well
interesting
yeah i didn't really want to kill jiren
oh okay well hey we know at least
wow that's crazy okay damn
i
i figured like i don't think she's
stronger than rinala but maybe
no she's not okay that's funny all right
let's help bach
uh bach should be in the capital now
right
here
that's a fate worse than death man
maybe ronnie helped ranala potentially
yeah maybe
all right is he here there he is
block the seamster your service master
all right i know this i know this quest
line though do you guys want us to help
bach or do you want to see uh bach die
[Music]
master
did you see it
the
the herb tree
oh you oh
i don't really have the words for this
but i was so
so dazzled i felt something stir in my
breast
the old tree is waiting for you master
he he definitely dies at the end
i feel it in my bones
i did get the beautiful one
i'm sorry master
my apologies
your wardrobe includes the garb of the
old demigods
and i'm afraid i can't make adjustments
to them
whatever who cares told me once
that a royal seamstress would do them up
in a jiffy
just wait master
before long i'll be that good too
give the gold sewing needle
yeah we want to do this right
yeah is that a gift for my undeserving
self oh thank you kindly
but what on earth could it
oh
amazing
i've never seen a golden needle
not in all my life
with a spectacular royal crest to boot
are you certain that this is for me uh
bach is a demi human i can hardly
believe it
have faith in me master
i'll polish my craft enough that i
deserve this golden gift
i'll be the golden seamster
now i'll be able to say anything
even the threads of the demigods
that's actually kind of sick
okay uh i have a favor to ask surely
she'd be happy for you have you ever
thought so
um
also can i change the way i look with
this on no okay so
i have a favor to ask master
may i ask you something
would you mind if i called you lord
i heard that you and the other yeah you
[Music]
[Music]
so please if you would
allow me to call you lord
yes or no
[Music]
yay or nay
no
[Music]
i mean why not what's wrong with him
calling me lord
well i don't think that affects anything
[Music]
yeah i'm seeing a lot more yays
and some knows as well
i'm saying yes you don't say
thank you this is what he wants you
my lord my lord my lord
please become elden lord
and please let i block the seamster
remain at your side
oh you guys are weird okay surely she'd
be happy for you do you think that mum
would be pleased if she knew oh my god
this is so sad is any royal seamstress
yeah i want to be out there lord of
course
i need to learn how to sew from scratch
like her
[Music]
hold on let me uh turn on
my lord please dude
turn on this light
bulk the seams ready to make
lord
have you ever wished you might be born
again oh god well
they say that ronaldo of reya lucaria
has the power to help people be reborn
oh
me
reborn
oh look at me
when you're this ugly
well being reborn it would hardly make a
difference i'm afraid okay
so do we tell him he's beautiful
or do we not tell him he's beautiful
i'm going already my
[Music]
i'll make a poll for that one
[Music]
beautiful yes or no
i have a feeling you're all gonna say
yes so i'm gonna get this prepared
[Music]
you're all saying yes so you don't want
to see him pretty much die
i believe this saves him if we tell him
he's beautiful
[Music]
he is a beautiful soul you guys are all
so nice
[Music]
thank you mom
[Music]
he's morally beautiful all right i'm
gonna tell him he's beautiful
you're beautiful
bock the seamster ready to make a joke
did i just hear my mum speaking
thank you very much
mum was always the only one who said i
was beautiful
and now my dear lord let me hear her
voice
please if i may dream just once
do you feel the same way my mum did my
lord
do you think i'm beautiful despite these
looks
oh let's ru now we can just rub it in
bro
oh no
oh god okay this would be way worse to
do that you're beautiful from his mom's
voice and just say no
oh
no
that would be so mean
[Music]
don't be a [ __ ]
all right you are going to get a timeout
because you are mr spammy spammer since
no spamming please
say yes new poll i know what you're all
gonna say if you said yes to this then
it's definitely saying
yes to keeping it that way
[Music]
okay
[ __ ] did i just thank you mum and now
do you make him earn it
[Music]
my lord
my dear lord
i
bock the seamster i'm forever in your
service
may the throne of elden lord be yours
okay so where does he go from here
does he just stay here now
i'm trying to think
what else we need to do
we haven't beaten uh el element here we
could probably do that
[Music]
that would have been extremely savage
though oh we need to go in the sewers
all right shaded castle or the sewers
down to uh
to moog's spirit
[Music]
[Music]
show me caleb i mean caleb
[Music]
created castle
not the sewers i hate that place
shaded
i mean we might as well
let's do it
gotta i probably have time to do this
and then we're gonna have to come back
tomorrow
i got some stuff to do
we
i might go play golf today
[Music]
or go hit some balls
moogs in the sewers
i'm pretty sure we got uh
millicent stuff
and already gave it to her but we didn't
go to elmer ellimer
yet
let me go check real quick
out of my way peasant yep we did okay
what is elmer lore
he was the executioner for house mirai
and then he betrayed them
uh took over this castle
and i'm pretty sure uh he's obsessed
with melania
because they both have uh afflictions
why did i go down here
elmer doesn't sound like a woman's name
that sounds like a dude
i don't know it could be i don't know
anybody's name a man or a woman
they don't [ __ ] matter
you a dog
i'm pretty is moonville still
overpowered for pvp
i've barely used it
holy [ __ ] i hate those guys
oh also i up i updated the uh discord a
little bit
with some new channels and stuff
you guys should go check it out
if you want
bye
what she fell
links in the description for the discord
all right eleanor
i timed you out because you were
spamming
you don't need to spam
[Music]
i'm dead
jesus
this guy's relentless
[Music]
oh that pissed me off like he just kept
throwing it
i needed one heal
jesus
i just someone banned [ __ ] demonize
so annoyed
i just answered that
with the monitor
oh come on bro
there were some
nice
yeah i'm over this guy
gone
he's used that
his sword does look really really cool
but it's so it's bad i tried using it
for a little bit it's it's just not good
it's bad
[Music]
wow we could sell a lot okay
so we got elemer nice
let's go
here
but
arcane does it get better with arcane
i just remember not liking it
yes we gave millicent has been she's
good
we'll see him in the mountains
but not the best uh not the best
weapon
i need six more smithing stone fives
what build are you going for soldier of
god rick
as you can see the fun build
why don't you do the rodrika thing
pretty sure we can do her at any point
we still don't have smithing stone fives
but i did do roderick he's good
yes phillip
already yes it's a chad built you could
say
you mean your soldier godric no i'm the
soldier of god
named rick
okay
um
[Music]
remember i need to do that as well okay
trying to debate if i need to get off
now i think i do
unfortunately
[Music]
i do
i want to go play golf that sounds fun
okay
that
that was great stream i had a fantastic
time
up my
my freaking controller
the game really doesn't like it when
your controller dc's
but i hope you all had a great time i
did
um i'll be back tomorrow more likely
than not
around the same time so
look forward to that um i did just redo
the discord so if you guys want to join
our discord we've got a lot of cool
channels in there that i'd like to to
fill up with cool [ __ ] that you guys put
in there so that's all linked in the
description a lot of other stuff linked
in the description as well if you're
interested go check it out
uh we are getting really close to 60 000
subs so i think we can get there by
the end of the week at the at the latest
so that's awesome thank you very much um
other than that you all have a great
rest of your day have a great night
hope all is well
and i'll see you guys soon so y'all take
care
thank you very much